an eu-us trade deal more prosperity or
lower standards mep s are divided but at
least they now know more about what's on
the table since the commission released
some of the documents as Parliament had
demanded t tip as it's called has been
discussed in the Environment Committee
where the reporter flagged up about
other issues us opposition to the e
u--'s reach laws on hazardous chemicals
it's about preserving Public Health it's
about preserving environmental standards
and if the Americans see that as an
obstacle to trade I think they're we
have a problem others see the reporters
to anti-american changes to standards
don't have to be one way so there's a
big globalization in this world when
Europe is not able to do everything
alone so we need partners and to we can
educate our part that's why not the
international trade committee discussed
its own t tip report by its president
burnt Langer some things like food
safety public health and the
controversial disputes procedure may
prove non-negotiable but there are also
potential benefits for Europe